foreign
[Music]
on YouTube I have I was playing in an
OTV tournament and I've been sick so
I've paused the speed run for a bit
but we are back
just really quickly the story behind
this name is an expression that I
sometimes use
which is like the way that I was
explaining certain Maneuvers by pieces
like sometimes you have to make a
retreating move
and I compared it to flying through
different airports but anyways I won't
delve into right now let's go
okay we're White against the 1200 no
this guy's not provisional so we're good
and we're gonna play E4
so once again here I am playing my
official
opening recommendations against all
openings
and against the Sicilian I've
recommended both the allopin as well as
the Smith Mora
it's been a while since we've actually
played the elephant and I feel more
comfortable kind of officially
recommending the elephant because I know
it better and the Smith Moore and the
Elephant are in many cases one and the
same
uh in case black plays Knight F6 the
smithmore and the Elephant are the same
opening
uh but of course against the immediate
C3 black has many other systems
the other main system
is d75 here which has fallen I think a
little bit out of favor in recent years
but still has a very good reputation
Knight F6 and and D5 are the two
the only two moves that are considered
to equalize comfortably but even they uh
you know obviously lead to very very
interesting play Knight F6 is our
opponent's Choice impressive
okay so of course the move here is E5
and now the Knight swings over to D5
kind of alakai in style this is sort of
an alkyne with the inclusion of the move
C3 and C5 which obviously favors black
because C3 is the square that we want to
use for the development of our Knight
um and C5 is a move that grabs space in
the center
and now we play the move d4 we occupy
the center with our pawns this is the
idea of C3
and if black plays C takes D4
uh then we officially transpose into the
Mora you could think about the more a
move order uh if you had started with D4
CD4
okay CD4 is on the board so this is
theory
and as I've explained before the first
thing to remember is that white does not
actually need to recapture immediately
it's not a mistake to play CD
um and there is even the move Queen
takes D4 which I think Mark esterman
recommends in his and is more a book he
he devotes a little bit of time to it
but the main line is actually to leave
this D4 Pawn alone for the time being
using the fact that the Knight on D5 is
spin DC is not a threat and instead we
just proceed with our development with a
very flexible move Knight F3 this keeps
maximum flexibility
and as I've shared before in the opening
you want to start with the most flexible
moves the moves that you know are not
going to cost you the moves you know you
want to play anyway and Knight F3 is
just such a move because well you need
to protect the E5 Pawn this Knight is
never really gonna go out to E2 so this
is a very flexible move we wait for
black to put their cards on the table
and then we proceed Knight C6 our
opponent is following the main line
all right now we can continue keeping
this Pawn on D4 but there's no more
utility in that and this is a good
moment to remove the tension in the
center by taking on D4 that is just the
main line we're following Theory
so we play C takes D4
and
Sicilian players to know Theory with
black know that the two main moves here
for black are D6 immediately chipping
away at White's Central Pawn Mass
otherwise if this Pawn mass starts
moving forward the knights can get
pushed out of there seemingly
unassailable squares and the second move
is E6 black can start with E6 in order
to secure this Knight on D5 first kind
of an antidote against Bishop C4 but
black plays the third move G6 also
socially nothing
wrong with it
nothing terribly wrong with it but this
is I think considered a little bit
inaccurate because it's a little slow
first of all right it's it's a two move
developing move
and second of all even if black
fiancaros is Bishop to G7
uh the bishop is kind of going to be
staring at this Pawn chain it's going to
be biting on granite
it's going to be a granite Granite biter
so we have several ways to proceed we
have many developing moves that come to
mind I think most of you are probably
most attracted to the move Bishop C4
which is probably the move we're going
to end up playing
there is also nothing wrong with just
playing Knight C3 Knight C3 is a totally
viable move that will likely lead to a
trade Knight takes C3 BC and it'll
further solidify our Pawn chain so that
is an alternative that I quite like
but Bishop C4 just seems to be a little
bit more you know it carries a little
more power
because it forces the Knight back
essentially or if flag plays E6 then
black is combined the moves E6 and G6
and as we've discussed that leaves black
very exposed and vulnerable on a lot of
these dark squares in the center F6 and
D6 we can try to get our Knight
potentially then to D6 or to F6
so this already poses Blackwood the
decision
um my guess is that Knight B6 is going
to follow
no real other moves I mean Knight C7 I
guess is possible but that's uh not a
Tempo move
and considering how slowly black is
developing black can hardly afford to
play that and I'd be sick so of course
we want to stay on this diagonal
right we want to stay on this diagonal
so we drop the bishop back to F to B3
is there a bishop sack on F7 some of you
may be wondering
I think the answer is no I I I'm not
aware that this works Bishop F7 King F7
there's another check on G5 the king
just runs back to G8
and if you move your queen out to F3 in
that line then black and slide his Queen
over to E8 so I don't think that line
works I'm very impressed the way our
opponent is handling the opening thus
far I mean this is this is pretty
advanced stuff D6 chipping away at our
Center
so let me think for a little while here
how do we want to handle
this position
this is kind of an isolated Queen Pawn
position in the making potentially
uh and it will actually reach an iqp
position if we play e takes D6 so if we
play Ed black will probably recapture
with the queen and then we will get this
isolated Queen Pawn on D4 which is a
very common structure that occurs out of
the allopin in in many many cases
but we don't have to play e takes D6
first of all black is not technically
threatening D takes E5 that forces a
queen trade but it doesn't win a pawn we
have two Defenders on E5 and black S2
attackers
so an alternative would be just a castle
kingside
and you know the reason for Castle and
kingside would be that after de5d5 in
the event the black takes Our Queen we
can recapture with the rook and put the
Rook on a nice open file
but that end game doesn't seem
all that you know appealing to me it
just doesn't seem like it's in the
spirit of the position I want to keep
the Queens on the board so let's look
for other Alternatives well another
alternative would be to Target The Pawn
on F7 using the fact that black you know
has delayed the kingside development so
we can think about the move Knight G5
that that should occur to most people
um and then there's another move that I
think we're going to end up playing
which uh Mamba on Discord has just
pointed out
so Knight G5 hits F7
black can defend by pushing the pawn out
to E6
and then we can continue attacking with
Queen F3
can black defend F7 in that position yes
black can slide his own Queen up let's
say to C7
and if you look carefully at the
resulting position
it gets very very sharp it gets messy
but what bothers me is that the D4 Pawn
is going to end up hanging because we've
moved our Knight away and we've moved
our Queen away and we cannot afford to
lose the D4 Pawn unless there's a very
compelling reason to do so so there's a
third move here that I really like and
this is a subtle move this is not a move
that I think most beginners would
necessarily stumble on because it
doesn't necessarily have the kind of
ring it doesn't look immediately obvious
or maybe even immediately logical now as
I pointed out earlier the idea of the
move D6 is to play D takes C5 and the
reason D takes E5 is annoying is because
it essentially forces a queen trade
right after de5 black can take the queen
on D1 and we have to recapture awkwardly
and we also don't want to exchange
Queens because we have more space we
have more space in the center and the
effect of a space Advantage is greatly
diminished if the Queens are off the
board we just have less pieces with
which to attack so how do we actually
avoid a queen shred well by moving Our
Queen where to move where do we move it
will it make sense to support the
Central Pawn Mass with the move Queen to
E2 this is I think a very sensible
Sensible move that keeps keeps the
tension and keeps the Queen's on the
board now in order to make this move
work you need to be familiar with a very
typical tactic that occurs in the event
of Bishop G4 a move that a ton of people
in like the 800 900 range would play
pretty automatically let's pin the
Knight and you might get excited by the
threat of Knight takes D4
but Bishop G4 runs into a a super
thematic tactical sequence black does
not fall for it Bishop takes F7 very
good yeah Bishop takes F7 and Knight G5
I'll show you after the game so don't
worry about not visualizing it but for
now we can continue our development and
let's just Castle kingside
and note that once black Castle's King
side Bishop G4 actually becomes a very
unpleasant idea
and it's not unpleasant because we risk
losing our Knight
right as I've pointed out before one
easy way to evaluate the danger of a pin
is first of all to see whether the
pinned piece is protected by a pawn
and the second thing is whether the pen
piece can be attacked by an enemy Pawn
answer the first questions yes answer to
the second question is no the Knight is
not in danger but our Center is because
this Knight is an integral defender of
both of these pawns and so at this point
we have to prevent Bishop G4 at all
costs
and so the move H3 is a very important
one to throw in
hopefully that logic makes sense after
Bishop G4 Knight takes D4 would have
been a big threat as would D take C5
all right
so I would say whites maybe a tiny bit
better here we've got a little bit more
space in the center
we've got a nice Bishop on B3 aiming at
F7 we still need to develop our Queen
side
and another move that I'm thinking about
is Rook F1 to D1 just to position our
Rook on a nice Square support the base
of the pawn chain
and and put some pressure uh on black
screen notice that the C file is
actually open which may not seem
significant right now because there's
nothing really going on on the C file
but later on in the game if black drives
this queen out to C7 we might be able to
carry out a plan based on quickly
getting our minor pieces out and then
putting a rook also on C1 and putting
more pressure on the queen so that might
happen later down the line
why aren't we developing Our Queen side
pieces well we had more important things
to do
right I was explaining the logic Beyond
every move it was more important to
prevent Bishop G4 than to urgently
develop the queen side pieces this the I
think we're
everything in the position is defended
so I think we're fine okay d e we of
course recapture with the pawn
we don't take back with a knight here
that would just drop the D4 Pawn
so we take back with a pawn
and the D file now opens up as well
raising the increasing the appeal of the
move Rook D1 which we might actually
play next
to drive the queen to C7 it goes there
anyway okay Queen C7 so now this of
course attacks the E5 Pawn
now this attacks the E5 Pawn forcing our
hand
one two three attackers one two
Defenders so there's like two ways to
defend the E5 Pawn you can play rookie
one but that's passive
you want to accomplish more than one
task at the same time if possible and
here there is the move Bishop F4 which
simultaneously does three things it
develops the bishop
it protects the pawn and it sets up a
potential x-ray against black screen now
you might say well I see that E6 is a
possibility but The Bishop's gonna be
hanging and again it's not just about
the short-term ideas but about the
long-term ideas as well maybe later
you'll be able to tuck your Bishop away
onto a defended Square such as H2 very
typical kind of move in the London many
different openings and then E6 might
become a very devastating threat
so
uh you know so we're setting up
potential tactical ideas in this
position as well
okay and black is cramped
the bishop on G7 is still biting on
granite
I mean the move I would play with black
is just Bishop to F5 develop
Black's own complete Black Zone
development
and if black handles this position very
carefully I think black can equalize our
opponent is doing just that
because we've got two main options
the first simple option and this is the
obvious continuation is just to play the
move Knight C3
okay we can play Knight C3 and we
probably will end up playing that move
by the way just develop our pieces there
is also the move G2 G4 we can chase the
bishop out of F5 we can say get off me
get out of there and given how crammed
black is there aren't that many
appealing options for where the bishop
can go now when a beginner or a player
is just starting here's a move like G4
they think a move like that is totally
out of the question because you move
upon right in front of your own King but
again it's not like black has all that
much going on on the king's side whereas
we have all this beef sitting there on
the king side ready to secure the king
even further so G4 is not out of the
question I would consider it but it's a
little bit too outlandish right we'll
have the time and the place to make such
moves later down the line in the
speedrun for now I want to play in more
of a fundamentally sound fashion so
let's just go Knight C3
of course we should be careful about the
possibility of Bishop to d3o and that's
a tactical blunder
so remember a little bit earlier I
pointed out that there's this
possibility of playing E6 one important
skill that you should try to start
developing is to generalize ideas right
E6 is an idea
but you have to be able to connect this
core idea to potential tactical
executions so why is E6 strong well
because it opens up an attack on Black's
Queen well under what circumstances
would it be even stronger well be even
stronger if the move E6 itself carried a
threat as well then that would be a
double attack on something as well as
the queen
and what could it be attacking well
hopefully you already see the move I'm
kind of guiding you in the right
direction combine that with the fact
that we know there's a lot of pressure
on F7 The Rook has moved away from f8
what was The Rook doing there it was
protecting the F7 Pawn we can play
Bishop takes F7 a classic tactic if King
takes F7 then E6 is the Discovery
against the queen and black therefore
will have to drop the king back to h8
but that is a disastrous Pawn to lose
because once black loses that one the
floodgates kind of open on the king side
the game is far from over if black plays
King h8 but
this is a big step in the right
direction for us and we can immediately
try to launch an attack afterward
as a matter of fact it's really not that
simple after King h8 because there's a
couple of logistical problems in our
position that we'll need to solve I will
need to actually think after King G8
believe it or not
or I'm already thinking about what we're
going to do after King h8
yeah so our opponent is still still
shell-shocked a little bit I think
well King f8
King f8 puts the king closer to the
general danger zone and there's also
this very weak E6 Square
that has been weakened as a result of
the fact that we've just captured the
pawn that was defending it and King f8
puts the king and the Queen on forkable
Square so it makes an idea like Knight
G5 even stronger now you might say well
King h8 does the same thing if the
bishop moves out of F7 at some point
then maybe the Knight can jump into F7
and absolutely that's going to be an
idea which is why my initial Temptation
after King h8 is actually just to go
Knight G5 straight away just go for the
attack
but there's some complicating factors
here Knight G5 drops the E5 Pawn so we
have to be careful about that pawn we
also have to be careful about an idea I
mentioned earlier Bishop F5 to D3 which
is not to be trifled with that pins the
queen to the rook and wins at least in
exchange
the third thing that we need to be very
careful about
is that this bishop on F7 is far from
safe and black threatens to play E6
which I will fully admit I missed when
we were taking on F7 that traps the
bishop and simultaneously attacks it
with the queen
okay so let's think for a second
we might have to end up making a small
sacrifice here
okay I have an idea this is positionally
pretty deep
so we won't be able to help to save
everything at once that's the general
observation that you should make which
is that black has all these threats E6
is one threat Bishop to D3 is the other
threat now I pointed out that this sort
of stock attacking formation in such
situations is to move the bishop away
and then go Knight G5 and Knight F7
so it's very important for attacking
purposes to preserve your light scored
Bishop why is that not only because it
sets up these discoveries after Knight
F7 but also because it just keeps the
black king stuck in the corner it keeps
the black king stuck on on h8 so what
we're going to do here
is actually move the bishop back
straight away I'm not totally convinced
that this is the top engine move we'll
check after the game
but I'm pretty convinced that this keeps
a big Advantage right even though it is
a sacrifice it is a flat out genuine you
know
sacrifice we're sacking The Exchange
right we're allowing Bishop to D3 and
then Bishop takes F1 so we're
sacrificing The Exchange but remember
that we've already won a pawn and we're
going to have a massive attack a massive
long-term attack
uh after black picks up the exchange on
F1 and an exchange sacrifice is really
not that big of a deal it's it's not a
rook it's not a piece okay black takes
it our opponent playing easily at a 2000
level thus far so this has been really
really fun now we should pause here for
a second to make sure
we should pause here for a second to
make sure that Knight G5 immediately
isn't very strong but it's actually not
he or she it's actually not very very
strong because of Bishop to C4
Bishop comes back to C4 intercepting our
Bishop on B3 so we actually need to take
a Tempo to eliminate the light squared
Bishop so that our Bishop remains
uncontested on this diagonal and on the
next move of course probably we're going
to end up playing Knight G5 unless black
plague makes the very strong move Knight
C6 to A5
which is not an easy move attacking the
bishop on B3 and trying to dislodge it
from this diagonal
and then I think we have a very strong
response in return
yeah we can handle maybe our opponent is
speed running as well but I think I
think black is in big trouble here
I think I think practically speaking
black is in huge trouble
just because I mean look at the build up
of pieces all over the place that are
all aiming at the king side I mean if
black can hold this then I'm tipping my
hat
I'll tell you that the move I would play
with black I really don't think our
opponent's gonna play it as Rook d8 to
f8 I'll explain that move after the game
that just might seem very mysterious to
you like why are we moving The Rook away
from an open file
but if I were playing Black here I think
the best defensive approach might be to
go Rook f8 let's see what our opponent
comes up with though
again it barring a move that creates a
threat our next move is going to be
Knight to G5 this should make sense to
everybody
foreign
we have a bunch of other ideas of course
bringing the Knight to F7
or to E6 isn't the only idea of the move
Knight G5 notice that the Knight also
aims
at the H7 Pawn so what can we do well we
can also then bring the queen over to H4
another very thematic attacking idea and
just launch a frontal attack against the
H7 Pawn
so there's just an abundance of tactical
ideas here for white
and again it's super important to point
out if you're a newer player that we
haven't sacrificed that much we have
sacked in exchange which is a bishop for
a rook but we also have a pawn
so from a material standpoint it's like
we've sacrificed one point of material
it's really not that big of a deal
what what does that really mean it means
even if our subsequent attack were to
backfire The Game Wouldn't automatically
end I mean the game would continue we
have a lot of positional assets as well
we still have more space in the center
black steel has pretty shoddy pieces so
we haven't made that big of an
investment here I don't feel that
nervous
and you should always remember that you
know when you sacrifice anything it's
like what have I sacrificed and if it's
really not that much then you shouldn't
throw all of your eggs in one basket or
Panic if your subsequent attack doesn't
work out
which is I think a very common
type of problem at many levels is like
when Upon A sacrificed and then you
don't Checkmate in two moves you know
people panic and just throw all of their
pieces at their opponent
okay no no no he this guy's 150 percent
legit I just I just think he's genuinely
underrated Knight A5 okay
so
here we need to prioritize and we have a
couple of good moves here we can keep a
huge advantage
with the move
we can keep a huge advantage
with the move Knight to G5
and if we calculate the variations
Knight G5
black is probably going to play Knight
takes B3
and then we can play Knight F7 check
that's an Intermezzo an in-between move
King G8 another in between move we take
the Rook on d8
but then in that resulting position
black can move the B3 Knight back to C5
I'll show this after the game as well so
you don't have to worry if you're not
visualizing this and things again get a
little bit messy I think white can get
out of that
preserving and at least an extra Pawn as
well as an attack
but I think there's a move that looks
more fun
and the move that looks more fun
although I'm not entirely sold on
whether we should play it is actually
Bishop B3 to E6 yeah Bishop E6 in order
to keep the bishop on this diagonal now
you might ask well why not Bishop F7
then but remember what's the F7 Square
going to be used for we want to leave it
vacant for the night very important to
do that what's also good about Bishop B6
is that the move Knight G5 defends the
bishop so after Bishop E6 Queen C6 we
can still play the move Knight G5
without having to worry about losing our
Bishop so let's set it up with Bishop E6
let's try it it's a risky move
the more conservative approach would
have just been to go Knight G5 straight
away but
you know we're trying to play good
attacking chess here
and time is starting to run low for both
of us so
this is even more dangerous in time
pressure
well that's what most of you are
probably wondering like what are we
going to do if black plays Knight a to
C4 well Knight C4 we can just like Queen
back to E2
we can even bring the queen back to C1
the queen is not really an integral
attacker here which is funny funny
though the the main part of the attack
right now is being conducted by the
bishop on E6 and the Knight on F3 these
two pieces are handling themselves
incredibly well the queen is just sort
of there as the glue piece to support
all of the other minor pieces make sure
they're not too loose
so after Knight AC4 the ideal Square for
the queen would be E4
but after Queen E4 you always have to be
careful about moving your Queens into
two vulnerable of a position because
then you run the risk of walking into a
queen trade so Queen E4 would be a great
example of that if your queen E4 black
has this nasty response Queen to C6
and suddenly the bishop is hanging as is
the queen so
there you have to walk into a queen
trade but that's not necessarily a bad
thing because Knight G5 Knight F7 can be
really strong even in an end game so
Queen E4 is interesting
but I think a far more circumspect move
in this case let me think for a second
the problem with Queen E2 is the black
then can play Rook f8 and suddenly the
bishop on F4 becomes loose that's one of
the jobs that the queen was fulfilling
all right I have an idea
I have an idea
we are actually going to play Queen E4
we are going to play Queen E4
and we're gonna meet Queen C6 with
Knight G5 anyway
so potentially we might get this into an
end game where we have an extra pawn and
a long lasting attack but I think it's
important here to keep the Queen close
enough to the other pieces Queen C1 I
think is also a good move
but to be completely honest Queen C1 I
was worried about dropping this E5 Pawn
which I think is also an integral
attacker because it's closing off the
bishop it's just adding a lot of fuel to
the fire
so I think it's more important to keep
everything nicely Compact and protected
now some of you might be wondering what
about the B2 Pawn are we not worried
about losing that pawn and then the
knight's gonna be hanging well we can
kind of ignore that after Knight takes
B2 we can still go Knight G5 and it
should make sense to you that if black
then takes the Knight on C3 Knight F7
and Knight takes d8 is just gonna win
back The Rook immediately and it's just
going to lead to a totally devastating
attack so the queen side is of least
concern right everything's happening
in this square of the board
well Knight D2 is not really a source of
danger we have two minor pieces guarding
that square the bishop on F4 is ain't
going anywhere I'm not worried about
this Fork at all
okay so hopefully my explanations thus
far have made sense our opponent is down
to three minutes
this is getting iffy Rook Cafe great
move by black
okay
um let's think
let's think I have a really cool idea
but I don't think it quite works
white is better but it ain't easy
we can go Knight G5 obviously but the
problem with Knight G5 is that then we
drop the pawn on E5
I think we're gonna make the move
very tempted to play Knight C3 to D5
my other candidate move is B3 but then
black can actually sack
The Rook on F4 and collect the pawn on
E5 and kind of break the flood gates
open a little bit
huh Rook f8 excellent defensive move
I think we're gonna go with Knight T5
I think we're gonna go with Knight to D5
this is a bit of a hard move to explain
but the basic idea is that in the events
of a trade on D5
the Knight on C4 is going to be hanging
and on top of that Queen C6 is going to
stop being a headache for us
because there's there's a piece on D5 if
blackface Queen C6 here then we're still
gonna go Knight to G5 which is a risky
risky approach we have a lot of loose
pieces there
but also E5 is not going to be hanging
because the queen will have moved away
from C7
so this is a way to try to
simultaneously manage the threats
of Queen C6 and Knight takes E5
now if I were black here I would
consider Rook takes F4
Queen takes F4 sacking The Exchange back
in order to collect this E5 Pawn
but in that resulting position white
still has a long lasting attack and
white still has Knight G5 so I think
we're gonna we're gonna get the job done
there
and we continue to poke and prod and
Knight takes B2 now this has to be a
mistake
yeah our opponent is getting very greedy
now we have two priorities in this
position two things that we can
prioritize we can go after the Knight on
B2 which is
a very very vulnerable night but it's
going to be hard to trap it for tactical
reasons and the second thing we can
prioritize is of course the move we
wanted to play for like 17 years now
which is Knight to G5
and I think that Knight G5 is a good
move we can start by playing Rook to C1
as some of you are indicating you can
absolutely throw in the move Rook to C1
activate the Rook first but that's not
strictly speaking necessary all right we
can also just keep the Rook on F1 for
now
um Queen D4 does trap the Knight
technically but
but remember that the queen is also
protecting the bishop on F4 and The Rook
is pressuring the bishop so Queen D4
doesn't actually create a threat let's
instead go Knight G5 I think we should
first play this move
and then a little bit later
we'll see what's going on on the queen
side
this is going to be close I mean this
attack might succeed
and also might not succeed I think I
just missed a brilliant defensive
resource
let's see if our opponent finds it
but even in the event that this move is
played it's still incredibly dangerous
for black
so that's the great thing about these
attacks is like even when your opponent
finds a bunch of good defensive moves it
doesn't the game doesn't end and there I
think is the Panic move okay Queen takes
F4
so obviously notice that Knight F7 check
here would be a very common very very
bad move okay our opponent collapses our
opponent collapses
uh and and carries out the right idea
but in the wrong in the wrong moments
yeah so there's a couple of ways to
punish this a lot of you guys are saying
Queen takes E5 check which is a very
pretty move followed by Knight F7 Knight
takes C5 up a piece but
but
you have a huge attack so there's zero
reason to actually trade Queens here
unless you're forced to do so I like
starting with Knight F7 Chuck
oh Queen F7 is just mate yeah or no no
it was not made black at E6 Queen F7
blackhead E6
which I I will admit I didn't sequin F7
but I'll show you after the game
now Queen F7 E6 yeah
no there was no made on H7 there because
the queen on C7 was protecting it okay
black walks into another discovery
and here
a lot of players would struggle to find
the most accurate execution there is a
very nice move in this position that
ends the game immediately
so
of course there's nothing wrong with
Knight takes E5 check
but let me walk you through kind of my
logic here
so Knight H6 check is a bad move
because then the king just steps up to
G7 what is your idea Knight H6 Jack King
G7 no follow-up
so
what I see is that the queen and the
bishop are defending each other
technically so there's another move
which I think it's harder to see this
move
because it doesn't I mean it just looks
very weird but it's actually incredibly
strong
and that's the move
um
so Knight d8 check is I think also
winning but the move I want to play is
Knight to D6 check
that's the that's the move we're gonna
end up playing
so this is a check first of all it's a
check
the idea is is to sever the connection
between the queen and the bishop so that
we can take on E5 with our Queen
and not only do we want to take on E5
with our Queen that's going to be a
check because the black king has only
two Escape squares G7 and h8 after king
h8 queen takes E5 is made in one because
the bishop covers G8
after King G7 Queen takes E5 check the
King has then two retreating squares
there's King f8
then Queen h8 is mate and if King H6
then we again use the placement of the
Knight on D6 and move it away to F7 that
is also simply Checkmate but even if it
weren't Checkmate it would win the queen
on C7
so it's just one of those moves
yeah that's it Queen takes E5 it's made
in two actually from this position
and here we go Queen h8 with mate
yeah very nicely played by our opponent
Kudos not an easy game at all
so let's review
let's review that was that was a pretty
rich game
how did I find this Pro I mean method of
exhaustion you just look at all the
night moves I think people really
underestimate when you have a potential
discover check just look at all of them
and spend 5-10 seconds on each potential
uh each potential discovery
so uh well again our opponent played
well but
how again as I always say how would you
feel if you played a really good game
and you tried your best and then you
know an entire chat was just randomly
accusing you of cheating or stream
sniping so that's that's not right I I
always make it clear if I'm actually
suspicious of someone it was very clear
from the first moves this guy is totally
legit
so just maybe underrated or you know
played it played a really nice game
okay
so we played an alopin Sicilian C3
Knight F6 E5 Knight T5 T4 CD this is all
Mainline stuff
and uh first important moment is here
don't forget to play the move Knight F3
the downside of playing C takes D4 is
that you're well there's really no
downside I mean most of the time it
transposes after Knight F3 Knight C6 to
the main line
but there's just this additional option
you're giving black of playing the
immediate D takes D5 so it doesn't
really matter
but uh the move Knight F3 is is how the
clinical
players players players play it so
Knight F3
black responds with Knight C6 main line
and now C takes D4
um so here the main move by far as as I
pointed out is the move D6
and this move should make perfect sense
to everybody you're opening up the
bishop you're chipping away at White
Center and this frequently leads to an
isolated Queen Pawn position so I'll
quickly rattle off the main line from
this position usually white plays Bishop
to C4 attacking the Knight on D5 the
Knight drops back to B6 with tempo
the bishop moves up to B5 pinning the
Knight on C6 and now you get this series
of Trades de5
95 attacking Knight on C6 from two
different sources black defense of
Bishop D7 and most of the time white
grabs the bishop to get the bishop pair
and here you get this classic isolated
Queen Pawn position
where
both sides of very clearly defined
assets white has the bishop pair
and in a position with a relatively open
center Bishop pair is pretty valuable
whereas black of course has direct
pressure on White's weak isolated Pawn
as well as full control well not full
control but relatively good control of
the square in front of the pawn which I
pointed out many times is one of the
most important aspects of iqp positions
who has control of the square in front
of of the pawn can you make sure that
it's a steady Target
but in many situations
the move d4 D5 actually comes a lot
faster than you might expect so for
example the main continuation here is
Castle's King side
and now recent books have recommended
for black to move A6 here immediately
resolving the situation
with the PIN
but the old main line and this is what
people used to play automatically is
just the developing move Bishop E7
and Bishop B7 oh and we have a question
from lost in the woods why does black
play E6 and not take the pawn you cannot
take the pawn here because after Queen
takes D4 the Knight is pinned you can't
move the Knight it's been to the king so
this Pawn is currently Untouchable and
the reason you don't play G6 here is
because white plays D5 right you need to
immobilize the pawn here you lose the
Knight on C6
that's okay
questions are good so Bishop B7 is the
move
what is the drawback of the move Bishop
E7 now you might say drawback I mean
it's just a developing move developing
moves don't have drawbacks well almost
every move is a drawback and most of the
time the drawback has to do with losing
control of something it was previously
defending in this case there's this G7
Pawn which can be attacked with a move
Queen to G4 very important move
on this move hinges the entire variation
Queen G4
so black castles King side in order to
defend it
and now
unfortunately Bishop H6 does not quite
work
who can tell me why if you're watching
on YouTube pause the video try to figure
out why Bishop H6 is wrong here it's
actually a blunder
and it's not what you might think it's
not what you might think
nobody's gotten it so far
this is a trick question
trick question
there we go very good it's not Bishop F6
which is a solid defensive move but this
transposes back into the main line
but here suddenly black has Queen takes
D4
and everything works out for black
you're defending G7 the Knight defends
the Queen the knights no longer pinned
because the king is now castled
and white loses a pawn simply white
simply loses upon
um so yeah you can't play Bishop H6 here
first you need to eliminate the Knight
on C6 to protect the D4 Pawn
and only now after BC
you play Bishop H6 Bishop F6
and now you bring the Rook into D1 in
order to protect D4 and the game goes on
I had a game here against another GM
that I won white is considered slightly
better in this position knight from C3
comes up to E4
and this is a very very well known line
of the elephant which has been contested
now for many decades tons of games in
the database you can dig around here if
you want but that's one of the main
theoretical lines is this entire grujaha
with uh starting with the move D6
hopefully that made you know General
logical sense but there's also a ton of
Sidelines like I'm showing you this line
and on each move both sides generally
have like a ton of different Sidelines
for example in this position black can
play the move D take C5
defending the Knight with the queen and
white recaptures and now you can get a
bunch of end games like a while back
this line with Knight D to B4 was really
popular I still think this line
basically equalizes for black
um you can also play the more sort of
conservative move E6 which is the
drawback of closing down the bishop but
it protects the Knight on D5 yeah I won
that game I won a nice game in that line
but here white is considered slightly
better this is a little passive for
black
so we will get to these lines as we get
more alopin games but for now let's get
to G6
and uh here I actually think I don't I'm
not sure I responded in the most
accurate way I'm going to consult my
allop and book because this is a opening
theme speedrun I want to do it properly
I'm sure G6 is analyzed the move G6
would be a good decision for black after
com play but why can force immediately
his opponent to weaken the dark swears
okay so they recommend
they recommend Queen to B3 here
which is a version of Bishop C4 but it
doesn't allow Knight B6 with tempo
apparently Queen B3 gives a big
advantage
now if the Knight drops back
then you have the move D5 and the pawns
are set in motion this is terrible for
black black is nowhere to go and E5 is
protected
so black has to play the very weakening
move E6 and again this weakens these
dark squares and now you go Knight C3
getting rid of Black's Knight
and now they give
Knight takes C3 BC
and what's interesting if B6 they just
give H4 start attacking on the king side
H4 and H5
and if D6 or D5
then e takes D6
Bishop takes D6 and again H4 this very
interesting idea H4 H5 and just go after
the H file given how weak black is on
the king side
and it's basically plus minus
so that's actually the refutation you go
Queen to B3 Bishop C4 is a little bit
inaccurate because it allows the Knight
to drop back with Tempo Bishop B3 I
still think white is slightly better
here but not as much as after Queen B3
um in any case so Blacklist D6
and now we played Queen to itsu getting
the queen out of the line of fire of
Black's Queen
no the there's no PDF available I think
you have to buy the book
so Bishop to G7
castles castles and H3
and H3 to prevent Bishop G4 so just as I
was explaining before the game Bishop G4
is a very thematic tactical blunder
uh because of Bishop takes F7 check
something that you should memorize once
and for all if you've never seen this
before the idea uh deflect the king to
F7 now Knight G5 is a check
King has to move back and queen takes G4
not only has this one a pawn but it's
also exposed massive weaknesses in the
center 96 is now a huge threat Black's
King is totally in shambles
the one little modification to this
tactic that you should know
is that in some cases
um if the G5 square is protected by
Black's Queen
you have to be very careful that in this
position black can't play Queen takes G5
because sometimes even if
you can then take black screen remember
that White's Queen is also hanging so
I've seen a lot of players lose a piece
like that I don't have
a instance of that in mind right now but
just more abstractly
but after black castles of course Bishop
takes F7 is no longer effective because
the Rook also protects the square so
here we already have to play H3
the book is called squeezing the
Sicilian
by califman and salivyav
so d-e-d-e
is on the board
black plays Queen C7 and we bring our
Bishop out to defend E5 black brings
their Bishop out as well
we get our night out to C3 this is all
totally normal and of course here came
Black's big mistake Rook F to d8 what
should black have done instead well it
was the right idea to bring the Rook to
d8 it was just the wrong Rook black
should have brought this Rook to d8 in
order to keep the other one to protect
this all-important weakness on F7
now in response I was planning to do the
same thing Rook a to D1
and I think white is definitely slightly
better here no question about it white
is slightly better more space nice
position
but one plan that black could Implement
here
is to ask himself well what is White's
strongest piece what is White's most
annoying piece
well it's actually the bishop on B3 the
bishop is what's preventing black from
doing the stuff that they want to do
what is it that walk wants to do well
ideally black wants to take and go Rook
d8
and trade all the pieces off but this is
not possible because again if this
bishop takes F7 tactic
so you might say oh well then let's
trade the Bishops with Bishop to E6
but that's also a very bad move from a
positional standpoint look what you're
doing to your Pawn structure and look
what you're doing to your other Bishop
so is there a way to actually control
the C8 square with another piece so
there's two ways of doing that you can
try to go Knight A5
and force White's Bishop back to C2 but
here you're allowing Bishop F7 anyway
this is a beautiful tactic
now you might say well didn't you just
say Rook takes F7 happens no but after
E6
note the consequence of Knight C6 to A5
what was the Knight doing on C6 was
protecting The Rook on d8
so now after Queen takes F4
if the Knight were to be on C6 here
black is fine black has two pieces for a
rook now you simply take another Rook on
d8 so a really really cool tactic
that's why you always have to pay
attention to what's going on on the main
open file
so the move here the best move and I
just checked the engine is Queen C7 to
C8
this is a super high class positional
move you should pay attention to it it
gets the queen out of the line of fire
of the bishop but more importantly It
prepares the move Bishop F5 to E6
eliminating White's strongest piece
um
so there's not much the white can do
about that like Queen E3 Bishop back to
E6 and black should be able to equalize
with a couple more careful moves Queen
C8 is a phenomenal positional move
um it's a move that shows that you
understand the position
so black in the game makes this big
tactical mistake Rook fd8 allowing
Bishop takes F7
but correctly reacts with King h8
and
we decided
that the most important thing was to
keep this bishop alive and we dropped it
back to B3 sacrificing The Exchange
once again the reason I didn't attend to
this threat of course ideally we would
make a move like Rook F to D1 but the
problem is the move E6 and the bishop on
F7 is trapped and it's hanging and if
you protect it with Knight G5 blackened
just dislodged the Knight with H6 this
is the problem right and you might say
well don't you have like Knight takes E6
here not really
because black first takes on D1 with
check
and then takes on F7 with the queen and
keeps the extra piece that doesn't work
now maybe white can get out of this with
some sacrifices or some Knight B5 moves
but now the queen slides over to E7 and
keeps contact with the bishop so I
didn't like this yeah you could play G4
here you actually probably have to and
what's funny is that Black's Bishop is
also trapped but now you're creating
major weaknesses on the king side
and after Queen takes F7 GF Queen takes
F5 black has won a pawn out of this
operation and Black's gonna win another
one on H3 on the next move and White's
King side is in shambles so
not a good outcome here for white so
that's why I didn't play Rook FT1
I considered the move Knight to B5 here
straight away but I didn't like it
because after Queen D7 the threat of
Bishop D3 becomes even stronger because
now the knight's also loose
so I thought maybe E6 but now the queen
drops into D3 and it basically has the
same effect that the bishop the move
Bishop D3 has it's also a fork and in
the event of a queen trade now you get
the actual fork and white loses more
material and the bishop is trapped on F7
so largely I found Bishop B3 by process
of elimination sacking in exchange is
the you know the most innocuous of the
sacrifices and it keeps all of the
attacking options alive
so Bishop D3 Queen E3 takes takes and
Knight to A5 by black a good defensive
move
and Bishop two E6 so once again I I was
contemplating the move Knight G5 instead
and I was calculating the line Knight
takes B3 Knight F7 check King G8 Knight
takes d8 and suddenly Rook takes d8 a b
with an extra Pawn for white this would
have been the less adventurous way to
just solidify the advantage but I wanted
to Checkmate so we wanted to keep the
bishop alive Bishop to E6
right AC4
and moving the queen up to E4
lost in the woods asked did you ever
consider attacking by pushing the H Pawn
going after the hook on G6 yes but it
would be too slow
such attacking ideas are good when the
center is closed when the center is wide
open essentially you have two moves I
mean every move has to create a threat
because look
how much is going on you know in the on
the Kings on the queen side and in the
center you just don't have the time for
a three move idea otherwise yes the H4
H5 is very thematic in such positions no
question
oh hey Ethiopian [ __ ] I think our
opponent has popped into the chat
um you played fantastic so what's funny
is that if we rewind a little bit
sorry no if we fast forward about a
little bit here here here there is a
move which comes Incredibly Close to
leading to a beautiful Checkmate and
this is a stock theme that I've shown
many times before anytime there is a
bishop controlling the G8 Square
and there is an H7 G6 formation you
should be aware of the possibility of
sacrificing something on G6 drawing the
pawn away from H7
and then opening up the H file and
delivering a Checkmate on that H file so
how do we
what is the the actual execution of this
idea here what's the move Knight to H4
with the idea of sacking on G6 so for
example let's make a random move for
black now Knight takes G6 works like a
charm and leads to force Checkmate you
don't care how much you give away
because as long as you keep the bishop
alive you're gonna have a mating pattern
like this
something worth remembering
um
and this is checkmate
and it's actually not easy it's not
possible for black to defend the G6
spawn
the problem again is that Knight H4
loses control of the E5 Pawn
and black in place simply the move
Knight cc4 takes E5
and we have a problem right if you play
Knight G6 stubbornly then after HG well
you can play Bishop B5 but at the end of
the day this is no longer Checkmate
because of Queen to H5
blocking the check this just doesn't
work out does that make sense
it just doesn't work out
so Knight H4 is a good try but Knight
takes E5 puts it to bed
um unfortunate
so anyways we decided on let's move
Knight to D5
basically refresh uh
one six sorry
it disconnected me for a moment there
okay ruining the coordination between
black species on the queen side why not
the immediate Knight G5 is what most
people probably wonder nothing wrong
with Knight G5 I think Knight G5 is also
a great move
I think Knight G5 is a great move as
well I was to be honest worried about
Knight takes E5
but apparently according to the engine
there is this weird move Bishop back to
G3
just to eliminate eliminate problems
with Rook takes F4
and you're you're essentially just
keeping a massive attack on black scene
Knight F7 is a threat using the pin
against Black's Queen yeah this would
have still been very very strong but we
decided on the Move Knight C5 playing a
little bit on both sides of the board
and after Knight takes B2 Knight G5 I
mean it's such an unpleasant situation
for black and here our opponent panics
I think that Black's Last Chance in this
position
would have been to use the fact that the
queen on e4 is a little bit overloaded
it's protecting the bishop and it's
trying to supervise
you know it's trying to put this Knight
on her house to rest so what move comes
to mind as a way of exploiting the
overextended nature of the queen trying
to reduce the tension a little bit on
the king side yeah Knight before the D
Knight B2 to D3 would have been very
strong here Knight D3
and the idea is after Queen D3 you play
Rook takes F4 and you're using your
extra material as a bargaining chip
again as as you often do when you're
defending so a lot of you might say hey
but what about 96 but that's the whole
point you're you're saying come take my
exchange at least I've gotten rid of the
night and black is actually totally fine
here material is equal this is an equal
position
so after Knight C3 white is probably
best advised to not take the Knight and
instead to move the bishop back and keep
the attack going
but here maybe black can get away with
Bishop takes E5
and I don't know 96
the engine gives Queen to C3
very difficult position to understand
but at the end of the day you're going
to get something like something like
this where the engine gives plus 1.3 so
white is still much better the attack
continues but perhaps black could have
preserved practical defensive Chances
with this very strong move Knight D3 but
not an easy move to to player to find
and it's not easy to follow up after
Bishop G3
so Rook takes F4 is a totally
understandable Panic move and after
Queen F4 I think it's already basically
over maybe black should try H6
and this by the way is something that a
lot of players forget about
this move H6 as a way of Defending
against
the potential uh Knight F7 is easily
forgotten about the idea is to create a
Luft Square on H7
and I once saved a game like that which
I've shown before
a game that looked like it was over it
looked like Knight F7 was coming and it
was going to lead to smothered mate
this is for my first world youth Chess
Championship
we reached this position my opponent
thinks that he finds
a straight up win and he ends up winning
the tournament actually sahaj Grover is
now a GM he won the under 10 section
um with like a monster score so he plays
Rook takes E6
and this is a very scary looking move F
takes C6 Queen takes E6
King h8 Knight G5 and then suddenly
offers me a draw
and it looks terrifying looks like
Knight F7 is coming but in fact this is
a complete paper tiger
for the same reason that we are
discussing right now with what simple
move can black put all the threats to
bed
H6 yeah Aegis H6 with the idea of
meeting Knight F7 check with King to H7
nice little square for the king
sidestepping all the threats now the
reason I took the draw is because I
thought that white can achieve a
Perpetual check with Knight G5 check
I thought this was a perpetual
because after well if King h8 then
obviously this is a repetition of moves
um
but here white has the retreating check
Queen E6 to H3
King G8 Queen to E6 and there seems to
be no way of sidestepping the checks
what did I miss who can see what I
missed and as a hint I'll reach this
position
well kng6 Queen E6
yeah very good Twinkle Toes got it King
G6 Queen E6 and now the bishop suddenly
comes back from the dead and covers on
F6 there's no more checks but not
not
what somebody else pointed out which is
king h8 and queen H7 which doesn't work
as you drop the Rook on the other side
of the board so it's not that it's King
G6 and Bishop F6 would have defended of
course white does not have to sack the
Knight but then white is down a pawn and
he's losing another one and there's no
compensation there's no attack on the
king so just remember this idea of
meeting Knight G5 with H6 you don't
always have to get smothered mated in
those situations
uh these attacks aren't as dangerous as
they seem now obviously compared to the
speedrun game here we're also up a pawn
here we're also up upon and we have a
huge attack going so we can drop the
bishop back to E4 and attack G6 this is
completely winning it's like plus four
and now by the way H4 H5 becomes a very
serious idea
um
I may have prolonged the game Bishop fp5
Knight F7 check and last thing here just
considering all of the possible night
Retreats right
yields the move Knight D6 there's no
magical way of finding Knight D6 you
just have to stumble onto it
and the idea again is to block the
connection between the queen and the
bishop so that you can take on E5 of the
queen and set up another Discovery
against Black's Queen but that doesn't
even matter because this is simply
Checkmate doesn't matter there's a zebra
on C7
in any case
that concluded the game so it was a okay
our opponent played King f8 and walked
into this mate
yeah you just try all the discoveries
and and you calculate them and that's
all there is to it and of course also
black could have prolonged the game with
E6 but we just play Bishop takes C6 here
that's that folks thank you for watching
thank you for hanging out
and uh again everybody who supports me
on YouTube and on Twitch
keeps the content going
see y'all later
bye
[Music]